[Music]
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the dark age
podcast all right dark horse but
nonetheless here we are it's q a time
and uh we got the q's in the queue
we uh you know we do we do yep yeah uh
we got um just sort of endless tech
problems here
uh so i did not have um the questions
from the discord until just now and not
on them at all on the stuff going on
here um but now that i have them i also
have the little thing that i wanted to
see at the top of the first hour which i
will say next week as well but let me
say this with regard to uh the discord
community that i'm talked about a little
bit at the end of that last hour that we
just did an hour and a half two hours
something
join your fellow patrons on our discord
server where you can engage in honest
conversations about difficult topics
join a book club or unwind with virtual
happy hours and even karaoke young or
old left to right there's a spot for you
at the campfire
and some of the some of the discord
leaders shared some of the stats about
it's almost two years old and uh
they've done they've had
um 95 happy hours and so 95 years a lot
of lectures and book clubs and essay
clubs and poetry nights and short story
readings all sorts of great stuff goes
on the discord so i will say that at the
top of the hour
next time whereas right now we it's much
smaller audience for the q a of course
but so there is also a certain amount of
meeting
in person
despite the immense hazard of social
awkwardness that can arise
when face to face but nonetheless all
kinds of things are are happening in
this community it's very it's very
exciting yeah it is
it is it is so one of the things uh that
i say to the discord people every week
is vote on a question and we will start
off the q a with
a question from you guys each week they
had a tie this week i'm just going to
read the top one and then we're going to
go into the questions that have come in
and then we have if we have time at the
end
i'll come back to their second one okay
elephants have a tuskless gene and i
don't i don't know anything about this
i'm is reading it as it's written it may
be that none of us knows what to do with
it so we go to the next question right
now
elements have a tuskless gene on the x
chromosome that is dominant
there are no males without tusks
male embryos with the gene are
apparently aborted tuskless females have
half as many male children
okay tuskless females have half as many
male children
which makes sense um
right because they're giving one of
their exes to each of their male
children
and uh and half the time that's going to
be a dustless
male who apparently reported um
in uh in utero okay okay
um if you know if if it's this clean
like very little in genetics is this
clean but yeah but take take the story
at face value in terms of how it's being
presented to us i'll start from the
beginning elephants have a tuskless gene
on the x chromosome that is dominant
there are no males without tusks
male embryos with the gene are
apparently aborted tuskless females have
half as many male children
and what's not said here is it possibly
if you're homozygous
for the tuskless gene as a female and
you couldn't be as a male because you
wouldn't have two ex's but if you're
homozygous
um
as a female that may that may cause
my guess is that that's even more costly
for females
although maybe that's not the case um
but if tuskless females have half as
many male children
if they were homozygous for the
tusklessness they would have zero male
children so presumably
heterozygous for this condition renders
you
lower fitness for if you're a female
but not no fitness where if you're
homozygous you basically can't bear male
children
apparently and this is where i don't
even know what to make of this
apparently a similar gene has been
observed in humans i have no clue how
this could work or how it would evolve
can you explain so i don't know if we
can do anything with that because i
don't know what that means boy i want
you know five minutes to sit quietly in
a room by myself with a piece of paper
and think this through but well but i
also like
this is one of the differences between
you and me i want to see a a
well-written paper by someone who knows
what science is um talking about this so
that i can get a sense of like what
what what among what in this story is
actually as clean as it would appear and
what is
interpretation of sort of you know muddy
evidence and what does it even mean so
that you know the big black box and the
question for me is apparently a similar
gene has been observed in humans what
does similar mean here i have no idea
what's similar you know similar in what
way similar in that
um
when a male has the so there's something
on the x that when a male has he doesn't
survive uh
gestation uh but when a female has it uh
she seems to do okay but she but any
male child that she gives it to doesn't
survive gestation is that all that all
that has meant here by similar or is
there something where it's obviously not
actually about tasks but yeah i mean i
still want my five minutes in a room by
myself with a piece of paper yeah um but
there's something in this that isn't
adding up to me yet and i have a feeling
if i was to go through it in detail i
would get it but
first of all i'd like to know something
about the distribution in of tusks in
elephants right apparently all the males
have it
and the story suggests some females do
and some females don't
well then the story would suggest
that those females who don't don't
entirely do to the presence of this
allele and that may or may not be true
as well
if females are homozygous for the
tuskless allele they cannot give birth
to male children well i'm inferring that
from tuskless females have half as many
male children for me
the clean genetics that are implied by
the rest of the question are that means
that those tuskless females are
heterozygous they have two x's one of
them has the tuscaloos allele one of
them has the normal tusked allele
whatever it is
and any of their male children who end
up with the x that has the tuscalos on
it don't end up they are aborted
i get it
what doesn't add up to me is that it
seems like the story should therefore be
that
homozygous
dominant
females never produce male children is
homozygous dominant mean
if oh homozygous
dominant okay
a homozygous female can exist she will
have no tusks
and she will also not carry a
recessive tusk
chromosome she presumably will have no
male children she cannot have male
children that strikes me as the kind of
fact that we would be likely to know
maybe it was just discovered but so
something about this story isn't quite
adding up it's so extraordinary
it's a pretty extraordinary case that it
would have to be pretty new for us not
to run across it because it's such a
good example of so many
uh genetic concepts you might wish to
teach for example
so here's what i'm wondering are we
dealing in this question with
a
meiotic drive
which is counterproductive to the
elephants that carry the driving element
it would have to be this is a selfish
gene right or is this a case
of
um an adaptation
of some kind in which
tusk variation in females is
has some meaning and those who are
hitters i guess yeah the females who are
heterozygous for it um are more
resistant to elephant pox right
so this sounds the fact of male
offspring of females who have passed on
their tuskless allele
are aborted
sounds like this is a meiotic drive
question
an ultrasound
what's that logical connection because
it would be bad for your fitness if you
produced
embryos so my drive is just your stand
in for
non-adaptive so let me see my drive is
the category that you are using for all
of the things that might that might be
not adapted a gene is sabotaging the
fitness of the individual to increase
its own narrow fitness it has basically
rebelled against the rest of the genome
so let me let me spell this out so
there's a very famous case of this
called the t haplotype in mice t
haplotype results in a short tail that's
why it's called t haplotype and the
basic point is wait what
t for tail
okay um
i didn't actually know that part right
so
the point is you've got
two chromosomes that carry the same type
of information but they don't carry the
identical information so the two
different versions of the
gene are called alleles the t haplotype
allele
is a saboteur of the individual that
carries it if you have two copies of it
you're dead
right you don't survive to reproduce
you have only one copy of it then that
one copy is in a predicament that is
true at any
gene locus in which you have two
different alleles where since each
allele would love to get into the future
it would love to do so by excluding its
competitor allele on the other
chromosome but in general genes don't in
general genes put up with each other and
there's a 50 50 chance that any given
sperm or egg will carry a given
allele in which you're heterozygous
so the point here is
in the case of the t haplotype the t
haplotype results in the destruction of
all gametes that don't carry it i think
this is in males that this happens
so sperm that carry the alternative the
normal allele don't make it
so the only sperm that the mouse
produces have this
special gene which means that in
competition with other male mice in
sperm competition
the individual who carries the t
haplotype is hobbled because they're not
produced they're producing half as many
sperm as they might which reduces their
chances of winning in sperm competition
by 50
so it is bad for the fitness of the
individual who carries this thing but
the degree to which that individual is
hobbled in reproduction is more than
compensated for from the point of this
allele by virtue of the fact that if
that individual successfully reproduces
it will definitely pass on
that version of the gene right so it's
bad for the individual the gene has
rebelled against the rest of the genome
to its own advantage right it gets it's
doubly likely to be passed on rather
than a 50 50 shot it's a 100
of all offspring will carry it
um but the likelihood of producing
offspring is reduced
spectacularly
so
in the case of elephants and i don't
know that any of the story we've just
heard is true but i assume that it must
line up with something um the idea that
a female elephant is going to produce a
male embryo that will then be aborted
right elephants do not produce large
litters right i think they always
produce singletons i think they have the
longest gestation on the plant so like
presumably this would be super early but
that's yeah that's but nonetheless and
they're seasonal breeders so like that's
actually a big i think they're seasonal
breeders right at least you know it's
only once every anyway that's a huge
cost so even if we rewrite the story so
that embryos are aborted very early and
maybe they have a chance at reproduction
still that season right the number of
times a female will miss a season in
which she's well equipped to reproduce
and then she dies and doesn't get
another shot is going to be large the
cost of this thing is high
so what that says is either selection
has
screwed up which happens or sometimes
there are problems that can't be solved
elegantly
but more likely this sounds like a case
in which there's conflict within the
genome that is being uh that is resolved
in a messy and costly way
um so anyway that's the question because
the whole meaning of this scenario is
different if this is adaptive but sloppy
okay if this is maladaptive but
represents a selfish genetic element
producing this phenomenon that's a whole
different story yeah and then we're at a
levels of selection analysis like oh
actually it's not always you know the
genes it's not always the individuals
it's not you know it's not always that
one one part of the
the thing that you can categorize with
boundaries around it is
the thing that selection is under it's
like it it is always both and yep yep
all right
where have the questions gone to there
we go
oh this is the first question from
darkhorsesubmissions.com where you too
can ask questions right now should you
choose to
we have
i live in canada and if i'd like to
start a new job i don't have the option
to remain unvaccinated
novovac seems like a reasonable
compromise what are your thoughts
uh you know i keep forgetting to look
into novax i did it a long time ago my
recollection was that it is still spike
based that it lacks some of the
troubling phenomena
you know lipid nanoparticles for example
yeah um but i don't remember that in
detail and i don't want to
you know i don't want to guess at this
yeah no i i feel exactly the same way i
looked at it too long ago without at the
point that we didn't know as much as we
do now
um
but that
you know
at a gross level it would seem that if
we've got novovax which is
a traditional platform
protein i can't i can't i can't even
remember exactly but like let's just put
let's call novavax novax if you've got
novx and dna or adenovirus vectored
which is um j j or astrazeneca i think
as well or the mrna vaccines which is
visor moderna um if there's like these
three types
that the mrna vaccines seem to be from
what the evidence
that we are allowed to see
suggests uh the most likely to do you
harm
and
uh what we
learned from christine ben
who
uh we talked about her interview on
unheard
some weeks back okay yes um the mrna
according to her analysis is a european
scientist and uh like
biostatistician even maybe you think
she's dutch but
that's oh totally yeah yeah absolutely
um
try not to be wrong by trying too
precisely right but anyway her her
analysis she she's partnered with some
other authors on it but the the analysis
suggested that the mrna vaccines that is
to say the lipid nanoparticle vaccines
appear to be net negative in terms of
all-cause mortality that's harm than
good
the
adenovirus vectored vaccines appeared to
be
slightly positive with respect to
all-cause mortality and interestingly
and they didn't look at um
whatever novobax is right there as far
as i know
so
the interesting thing was not all of the
benefit of the adino
vectored
vaccine
came in the form of covet reduction and
so there was a question about
non-specific immunity being amplified by
it now i would still caution you
that
analysis is done
very shortly after these vaccines have
been deployed for the first time ever
what that means it does not mean that
the adenovectored
vaccine
is actually beneficial
what it means is that if the analysis is
right early in this process where we see
the costs and benefits at you know a
year and a half in
it appears to be beneficial that could
easily reverse if there are harms
that
you know show up two years five years
out that analysis could reverse so
you know if it were me
i would certainly want the adreno
vectored one
and i over mrna over the mrna one by far
um
right but neither of us know enough
about about the numbers
right to say but um
of those three types the only thing yeah
again as i said the only thing that is
clear to me is that the mrna vaccines
are the least good option the least good
option i would also say another thing
that is clear i think
is that
spike protein is a very dangerous
focus the production of spike protein or
the introduction of spike protein into
the body is not a cost-free thing yeah
which is to say therefore that the
vaccines uh that prod that provide it to
you or cause your body to produce it
or being exposed to covet itself
are all not a safe activity and that
means that you know we all live on this
planet where this virus was
uh created
and escaped and here we are and pretty
much all of us can end up exposed to it
somehow at some point but we all ought
to be looking to minimize that all right
so i just realized something
we have been talking a little bit about
the stabilization of the mrnas in the
lipid nanoparticle vectored
vaccines that the substitution of
pseudo-uridine
for the standard uracil
stabilizes these things which is bad so
they so that it persists so that it is
whereas it would it would not it would
be expected to get dismantled by
normal processes that take apart mrnas
um the mrnas is i never know how to
pronounce that but yeah you got it um
that will not
that will not be a feature of
the
adino vectored
because their mrna will be
downstream of a dna
so there will be no
presumably no pseudo-uridine so that
means oh oh i see but i see what you're
saying won't be won't be the case there
will have been no ability to affect what
the mrna itself looks like because the
mrna is not the thing either being
injected or being directly produced
right now what i don't know
is that i cannot say for certain that
there is no similar phenomenon with
respect to dna but i don't i think the
way the adenovectored
vaccine works should preclude this so
that in effect one of the things that
may be a
cause of the measurable distinction
between these two technologies is i
don't know that the information molecule
is
natural
it's natural in its chemical
construction and therefore dealt with
elegantly with the by the body and
therefore not persistent in a way that
can cause pathology over the course of
many months i haven't looked into it and
i've never heard of pseudo-uridine
so i don't know if we even produce it
i believe the answer is we do
we biologists don't understand the logic
of the body the rare cases in which this
is actually utilized in a normal process
it has to do apparently with
stabilization but i think what has
occurred
is that the manufacturers of the vaccine
used it liberally in the molecule they
produced whereas the body knows
when you know knows in the evolutionary
sense
when to utilize it to get a particular
effect and um but so it's not like
there's a whole bunch of it and
a whole bunch of it already it's like oh
there's just a bunch of use a bunch of
uracils and a bunch of pseudo-uradians
floating around and so like why not grab
one or the other it's like no it's
really always the uracil that gets
that
that gets used in rna i think so i
should ask uh robert malone about this
but my impression from what he was
saying about this is um that basically
we took a process that does exist
biologically but is
very sparingly used
and employed it technologically in a way
that changed this radically
um
fascinating yeah
what could go wrong
what could possibly go wrong
next question evolutionarily speaking
how has the brain changed now that we
allow blind people and people with
disabilities to reign in our tribes and
this person has spelled rain as if it's
precipitation um but i'm sure they mean
to
to lead in places you know people
people like me with lifelong myopia who
are yet
um
allowed to persist and
and um
and
well
rain in some cases yeah i mean it really
depends what the question means right
there is a way in which people who would
be
so hobbled by a disability are
technologically
rendered equal or close
and so they stick around and presumably
that has a neurodiversity benefit
which is that people who have different
strengths and weaknesses
contribute something to our breadth of
thought now in your case and the
population is so large that of course
there are lots of outliers that we can
point to people like stephen hawking
right who wouldn't have survived
very if he'd been born you know really
almost any earlier than he was actually
born and of course we all benefit from
his
from his thinking
right um so there are people that we
save there are people i mean there's a
great case with uh post encephaletic
babies babies who have a circulation
issue that causes water to accumulate
and drive out
brain matter
which would have always been fatal in
the past we've gotten good at surgically
reversing it but the crazy thing
is how
frequently
somebody who has had profound damage to
the brain
very early in development ends up normal
in some way that is ridiculously
neurodiverse right like you destroy the
back of the brain
by water accumulating there that ought
to make you blind because that's where
the visual cortex goes but the visual
cortex will then form somewhere else
which tells you on so many interesting
things one thing it tells you is that
there's no
thing in the genes that says place
visual cortex in the back of the brain
because there's no way a contingency
plan could have evolved since nobody
would have survived that damage
you know in the ancestral past i thought
what that told you is that we only used
ten percent of our brains
you only use temper
only use 10 of your brain oh that's
that's about right
but
so the point is um
those people have
unusual kinds of neurological
structures that have presumably impact i
mean no doubt there are deficits if you
could get rid of a large amount of your
brain
um hence the absurdity of this trope
that i actually haven't heard in a while
but you know used to hear all the time
like we only use 10 of our brains now
selection doesn't work that way
incredibly expensive to build and to run
the brain is so but no doubt if we were
to measure some of these people who have
lost a lot of brain matter very early in
development and then end up seeming
normal there would be a deficit
somewhere it's gotta be yeah um
but
anyway the uh you're gonna before i
interrupt you you're gonna say something
about in my case in your case i don't
believe that you have a genetic i don't
believe that we have evidence that you
have a genetic predisposition to credit
eyesight even though both of my parents
have myopia
yeah
um okay yeah no i think this is
developmental um and i think this is one
of the things that we learn you blame
the library yes you blame the library in
my home i grew up with the the walls
lined with books i blame the price of
ink and paper which caused small fonts
which caused people to bury their noses
in books and and the
the cultural value place in my home on
uh taking in another book down off the
wall and
reading it for long hours at a time
right especially early in development
where the feedbacks that might cause
your eyes to correct if you were you
know
hunting gathering whatever else you
might have been doing um didn't didn't
work out and so i think that a huge
fraction of the pathology which we
dismiss as oh errors in the genes
it's just it doesn't make any sense that
it could be right those errors wouldn't
accumulate so quickly they wouldn't be
so widespread um and so basically the
analysis that we would do for something
like the widespread and growing need for
orthodontia in children is the result of
a bad feedback where we disrupted
development likewise
i think the same thing will be true for
uh eyes and much else
but
anyway
what's the net outcome
um
probably we get some neurodiversity
benefit
uh
it is certainly true that to the extent
that genetic anomalies show up that are
bad and we technologically correct for
it right or behaviorally correct for it
that will result in those anomalies not
being selected against and so they will
accumulate that will have an impact
but i don't think most of the you know
the
kid pathologies are really about that i
think that's just nonsense interesting
okay
if
next question if memetic transmission is
in some way like genetic transmission
is there a corollary with gmos crispr or
something else
that could help us interpret what's
going on with our culture as related to
the interference of tech and media
yeah
okay i'm still processing the question
so you oh tick tock
is like
broccoli that's been dipped in pesticide
you know yeah no there's of course yeah
there's lots of um
bad cultural stuff that especially when
it's been made super delicious by people
who make money for your consuming it um
it gets ingested in large amounts and
uh you know it spreads but look let's
look at the the difference between the
jeans and the memescape
so that you know you just you know the
baseline
both teams and memes are hereditary
modes they are both
vitally important in human beings human
beings are
very special in the degree to which
things have been shifted over into
cultural evolution space rather than
gene space but the key thing is they
both evolve adaptation happens in both
realms
the adaptations that happen in cultural
space are actually there to serve the
genes sorry that's bad news but it's
true it has to logically be true for
reasons we've
gone into in our book and
have gone into on dark horse too but the
key thing is
the mutation rate over in culture space
is incredibly high
the rate of extinction of mutants is
also incredibly high so the point is if
you look horizontally across culture and
you say well are you claiming that all
of this is adaptive no huge amount of
it's garbage but it's also not durable
it's not going to last
we look into the genes and you know
your genes produce an appendix
we can be pretty sure that that appendix
is serving your interests in some way
and if we can't spell out what that way
is we know we have something to look for
you can't really say that with
cultural traditions that are only
available in the present something has
to last a long time before you're
justified in saying actually that's
somehow serving the interests of the
creatures that have it and
so yeah there's a lot of garbage and
especially now the market is doing
things to our cultural space
basically it's preserving a lot of
garbage because wealth is being
transferred from you to somebody else
and it's in their interest to keep you
confused
indeed
hello from new zealand
the 2019 gun confiscation here was 20
effective at best
since then gun crimes through the roof
and police struggled to recruit
be wary of the u.s media using new
zealand as an example
yes i think i've heard this about
australia i've heard part of it about
australia too that the the
the uh gun
um
i think it was not a buyback in
australia but there was an attempt to
reduce
uh the number of guns in circulation and
um it was
not nearly so effective as we are told
okay
i'm gonna
get some dust in my throat so i'm gonna
ask you a question and then you're gonna
skip it yeah
you want to store mouth as if i've said
something offensive
no
all right then
since hearing eric describe how
important warren zevonne is i've become
a huge fan
do you each
have one or two musical artists or
groups have grabbed you like warren has
eric
um
yeah there are there are a number but i
i think my
my interaction with music was changed
very positively
by
um
by pandora
and what i mean by that
is i was sort of stuck in a rut where i
was listening to the same stuff i
listened in high school and it wasn't
that
provocative or interesting to me anymore
so i was kind of in a less musical phase
because i didn't know what to listen to
all of which is very
uh unnatural you know in ancestral
circumstances
music is a living phenomenon where even
if you're listening to the same
musicians or more likely you're
participating in the production of music
and it's a limited repertoire of songs
every song changes every time
and so it's a very different
relationship to music right we have a
very novel relationship where
the uh
where a song can be identically
reproduced two times in a row you know
by playing playing the mp3 file or
whatever it is
um but so anyway i was in a musical rut
pandora which i'm pretty convinced
doesn't do what they say it does right
in theory what pandora is supposed to do
is
people who know music are supposed to
describe the attributes of a particular
song and then it is supposed to use that
information to find other things you are
likely to like based on what you have
liked
in the past i don't think that's really
what it does i think what it does is it
simply
takes people you know if you have liked
45 songs on pandora
then
[Music]
you can predict based on who else has
liked a large fraction of those songs
what thing you haven't heard you might
like right
uh so anyway it did that for me
and it found a bunch of things what did
that for you pandora okay it found a
bunch of things that i probably would
never have encountered on my own because
i was stuck in this musical rut
that do mean a lot to me that have uh
important influence so
you know there are various bands that
mean something to me that i probably
wouldn't have
you know prob maybe i would have
encountered radiohead and i would have
figured out that there was something
there that was important to me but maybe
not
um definitely spoon
i find uh especially lyrically
the arctic monkeys are often um
[Music]
quite uh insightful
um
cage the elephant is something i
probably would not have found it's very
it's got exactly the right gen x ethos i
think the right sensibility
um so all of those are
are very
significant i don't know that it mirrors
eric's relationship with lauren zivan um
but
you know and i you know eric is also
quite the musician and i just definitely
am not
i really like music i have a deep
relationship with music but i'm
frustrated that the only thing i can do
is sing
um
so
now i have in fact done right but i did
it in prose so
no i mean you're going to get asked to
sing right
um right which i will carefully
skirt that invitation but uh but anyway
i don't know that my relationship would
be the same as as eric's would be by
virtue of the fact that he has you know
he produces music and has taught himself
multiple instruments and and all of that
but but there are these few artists that
are
um
especially resonant for me and i'm glad
as an adult to have have found that
stuff
nice
i am going to um
i'm going to not answer the question now
not because i don't want to but because
it's the kind of question that i like
and i appreciate it uh but i have a very
hard time coming up in real time
with the right way to answer it so i
heard the second half of what you said
and um that all resonates um
i'm sure it's it's more it's different
for me i have a very different musical
trajectory
from either you or your brother
but
anyway i will stop talking
wuhan institute of virology published on
monkeypox research three months ago nih
also have been researching monkeypox
treatment
ntis i don't remember what the nti just
down what that stands for ntis fictional
monkey pox outbreak scenario start date
coincides with the current one
is all of this a coincidence
how would we know
how would we know there's an awful lot
of coincidence these days and it could
be of very many different kinds um
there's a lot of people doing a lot of
stuff coincidences will happen
coincidences will happen there's
something odd about monkey pox showing
up now i think we discussed it a little
bit given that it circulates in humans
and doesn't cause these multi-continent
outbreaks what happened now is that
downstream of any of the perfectly
insane pharmaceuticals that are being
thrown at covid these brand new
mutation inducing
drugs don't know but something is up
here and i guess we're gonna play a
guessing game where we have to figure
out what the missing piece of the story
is and uh stay tuned yeah indeed
um
oh
here we go
the assumption that you could find
homozygous with regard to the elephant
question uh the assumption that you'd
expect to find homozygous females with
no male offspring is wrong as every
female's father can't carry the gene oh
true obvious good
obvious and we both missed it yep yeah
true yeah so all females would be
heterozygous
or homozygous
for the recessive or homozygous or
heterozygous
yep um except
for the parthenogenetic
elephants well
um
the flccc vax injury protocol is out i
have found it helpful please take a look
so i saw this right before we went on
yep i've looked at it um
okay so yeah here it is um this is the
post vaccine treatment
they say first line therapy is
intermittent fasting ivermectin
low-dose naltrexone i think is how you
pronounce that yeah i can make this
bigger too um
melatonin aspirin vitamin c vitamin d
vitamin k2
quercetin and then now for that they've
that's that's what they've got yeah so
not too far off
so they also their uh prevention
protocol yeah it has a lot of the same
elements um they also have i think there
are two things on their site called i
recover one of them is long coveted and
one yeah i've actually got that other
one open as well is uh is vaccine injury
yeah this is long cove and it's actually
different it's interesting
a the first line therapies is a little
bit different fiber mechanist on there
but prednisone naltrexone again omega-3
fatty acids
vitamin d and then they've got second
line therapies which includes
fluvoxamine and
torva statin
um
they've got a lot of stuff on here that
i don't actually recognize including
like four different
successive kinds of
other kinds of treatment but of course
for long covered you might expect you
know there's just lost so many different
amounts of time that people may be
experiencing things yeah um
well uh there are a number of things
there's one thing on there
i recover from the vaccine
injury protocol
there's
a drug that is typically used to
reduce addiction to opioids so
i don't see that on here you sure no
drexel oh that's what that is the
naltrexone yep okay um
so anyway i've inquired as to what role
that is playing but you know
a number of the things in here are doing
something that is not their
primary yeah well there's something
around opioid receptors that one of mid
you know
i can't say mid who knows where we are
in this thing but
sometime between
march 2020 and now there was some
discussion of maybe
opioid receptors being involved in
differential response to code exposure i
think don't remember maybe a totally
different mechanism but you know we've
got aspirin on this protocol presumably
that's as
an anticoagulant not an analgesic
melatonin is on there melatonin has long
been understood to have some benefits in
the context of covid and uh that's not
i think it's not through the mechanism
of it allowing you to get more sleep
yeah well it might be related to some of
the stuff we talked about a few episodes
ago with regard to
um
know the the the benefits of sunlight
that aren't vitamin d include the
near-infrared
um
exposure that uh basically prompts this
you know this like circulating melatonin
as opposed to the
the form of melatonin that we think of
as being
on a circadian rhythm yep
um
i mean i think the overarching reaction
i have is you've got a tiny number of
doctors who have dared
to
experiment and figure out what works for
the patients that they're seeing
and you know i mean we have vaccine
injured friends and we've directed
several of them to these tiny number of
doctors who will actually treat them
how much better off would we be if
medicine in general was trying to solve
this problem and all of these doctors
could pool their knowledge and talk
about things that they've noticed that
work that don't work patterns that
they've seen right it's insane that we
would play this game this way that we
would demonize yep the fl triple c for
daring to
to acknowledge that there are vaccine
injuries into daring to treat these
people yep um
so anyway i guess what i would say is
look we've got a tiny number of experts
in this they're the people who dared
to um admit that there was a problem and
do the job of medicine that involves
trying to figure out how to make these
people suffering
less yeah
so you know more power to them so
speaking of the flccc uh we have another
question
um andrew huff who we don't know and i
looked up and i will show in a minute
here andrew huff's tweets from the 29th
suggest that he's in trouble he's had
home invasions and drones on his
property do you know if he's safe i
don't know if that name immediately
means anything to you it does it does i
figured it might so andrew huff's pinned
tweet which you can show here zach
is um you might have noticed that i've
oh wait first though his um
his bio on twitter is former eco health
alliance vp and whistleblower
army combat veteran scientist
entrepreneur okay
so
thread
um
last week i decided to check my trail
cameras scattered throughout my property
i noticed something very strange the
cameras that cover my driveway were all
missing a range of days from about may
through 15th i found this highly suspect
anyway you can you you go on you see
pictures and you see you see drones that
aren't his on his cryptic cameras
um
there's
something there i don't i don't
i i don't think we should do this in
real time
what do you mean do i see them i mean
he's talking this this thing in this
picture um
so i wasn't sure what to make of the
pictures oh you've seen this already
okay um so anyway this is the first time
i'm looking at them
um
i don't know anything about it
but
he's reporting that the cameras that
were obvious
had been offline and the cameras that
weren't obvious that were hidden
revealed stuff going on and he's
basically saying at the end
i have nothing to hide so i don't care
if they're snooping through my
activities however this is illegal and i
have done nothing wrong
i object to the formulation of i have
nothing to hide therefore it's okay if
you invade my privacy that's not okay
ever no matter what
but
there it you know there's a question of
what the hell is happening and um why
any of us are okay with the prospect of
if there is an invasion of privacy um if
it's happening yeah the problem is for
all of us
i don't know what to make of this story
it's utterly extraordinary
but
how would i know right and
yeah
i honestly don't know how we are
supposed to deal with stories like this
because if there are in fact you know
drones invading his property to spy on
him yeah having had the position which
i'm pretty sure he did at eco health
alliance and having been there for privy
to how that entity works well that is
pretty darn interesting on the other
hand
how would we know
yep
well
as always that is that is the problem
all right
next question last week you talked about
easy access to guns being part of the
problem yet gun murders per capita tend
to be higher in blue cities with gun
control and lower and red ones without
doesn't this falsify your claim
uh no
it is evidence potentially but you're
talking about a whole
suite of one-off
scenarios who've had
you know
does the fact that you're
governed by democrats mean that you have
the same rules no it tells you something
about the direction in which these rules
go but
the point is you don't have
comparable entities with which to say
doesn't this mean that
no
none of it means anything we could be
that whatever causes people to elect
democrats is some third correlate and it
has nothing to do with well i mean now i
don't know i don't know that this has
always been the case i hope it hasn't
always been the case but at the moment
um
bluer cities are more likely to have
defunded the police
right right so i mean that's just that's
an easy correlate right there that that
that we have to be considering right but
my point is
there are
25
potentially interacting correlates the
ability to draw any simple conclusion
from these patterns is dubious but it
doesn't mean that it isn't evidence
right so
it doesn't falsify but it is evidence in
a particular direction you can't pick
two variables put them next to each
other and say doesn't this falsify
because it's a complex system with a lot
of interacting variables
right
all right after brett's chat with neil
oliver it occurred to me that we are
living a literal stanford prison
experiment based on the behavior of the
elites in charge
thoughts
um yeah
so neil said
some things in there about the bullying
and the role that it was playing and
that
at the point that he saw that the what
came back was not an argument against
his position but a threat
um that he understood
he understood where he was because why
would you why would a threat be
necessary if there was an argument that
would stand in this place which i
i agree with that logic
why why the strong arming if if it's as
good as you say it is right and you know
i've used
different versions of the same argument
you know if the argument against
ivermectin's effectiveness is so
compelling
why are you strong-arming my doctor and
my pharmacist shouldn't you know these
people went to school to understand
these things if it really doesn't work
you should be able to show them the
evidence that it doesn't work and that
should be sufficient to get it not to be
prescribed and therefore
not to be dispensed so if you can't
convince them demonstrably safe from
decades of work and uh there is this
giant
um stockpile that got disappeared so
right well and you know if my doctor
thinks it probably doesn't work but it's
not going to hurt you and therefore the
small you know if my doctor thinks
there's a five percent chance that it
works
and a effectively zero percent chance
that it's going to hurt me to try it if
i'm sick with covid
right why are you stopping my doctor
from doing that yeah right that has to
do with something other than the illogic
of doctors it has to do with some reason
that ivermectin must not be dispensed
that we have not been told
indeed
if passed um
i'm going to go to this one next because
i don't i think there's a misspelling
here that's going to make me
mispronounce the word so i'll come back
to the next question
in a minute uh here we go
my local ontario data show that boosted
people have doubled the case numbers of
not fully vast people but can you point
me to a more rigorous source about this
trend
i haven't seen
i've certainly seen
many
sources that claim this pattern right um
have not gone in depth with any of them
but it
it is certainly suggestive
right that a vaccine that was initially
deployed
on the theory that it was going to
prevent
that it was going to slow the spread of
the disease now seems to be
afflicting people who
were vaccinated as much or more
yeah but i don't i don't have anything
more rigorous than that either
so we have
um
i think i've just lost my ability to
imagine that i can ever pronounce
anything correctly in french
so i've now talked myself out of being
able to do any of it you will be
familiar with the name here uh pierre
poilev i i just don't even i've never
even heard it said because i don't get
my news that way
um who is running for uh prime minister
in france against trudeau
he
uh his bills wait wait
in can i say frank yeah so sorry this
canada yes oh god yeah trudeau is not
running france
um
um
poliev who apologies for the terrible
pronunciation
um has introduced a bill c 278 uh which
would in the words of this question ask
her question ask her scrap and ban
vaccine mandates in canada
he has come out strong against the
vaccine mandates
i haven't been following along as much
as i was back
when the trekker's convoy was happening
and shortly thereafter but
he has been he has been
unabashedly
uh
against
the to the coveted tyranny that has
taken over canada and i don't know
actually i'm curious
how that is reading in various both
rural areas in canada and cities and how
it differs between them and
you know that the turkish credibility
was just galvanizing
and
you know i continue to hear regularly
from people who still think on that as
the sort of the one
ray of hope that they've had during
copenhagen to see their fellow canadians
stand you know get up and stand up and
and
link arms and say not this not that we
we are better than this
and i think that's what he's um i think
that's what
uh he is
speaking to
he looks like a good candidate for what
little i can see but i don't know very
much
well the irony
of the fact that it is extraordinary
that he would oppose these mandates
is
an amazing fact in and of itself because
at this point almost no matter where you
stood
with respect to the original wisdom of
the vaccine campaign and the original
wisdom of the vaccine mandates what we
now know
about
their
failure to prevent
the contracting and spreading
of covet 19
suggest that any normal person asked
should we be
mandating that you take these things is
there risk zero
no
should we be mandating that you take
them why would we um
well it's not to control the disease
it's to keep you out of the hospital
wait you're mandating this to protect me
from me
am i not in a position to evaluate my
own likelihood of going to the hospital
based on demographic parameters that are
now well understood
so demographic parameters and
comorbidities right so i guess my point
would be
as far as i know and i'm pretty well
informed on this there is zero argument
for these mandates that i i cannot even
steal man an argument because the
argument is so
incoherent yep that i can't imagine
yeah and that's interesting actually
like
usually when asked a stalemate a thing i
feel an obligation to think through what
that would look like and really to come
up to come up with a thing in this case
no i mean i this is this is not
sophistry but it's the same sort of like
we're going to create a thing
where
um in order for you to respond to it the
way we are telling you you need to
respond you will tell yourself in
circles like well
the the the mandating of the tying in
circles actually that's that's on you
guys that's not on us for saying no to
mandates um
because because
all of the evidence 100 of the evidence
points away from
their
their morality frankly right no it's
completely immoral but i guess you know
i have said
steel manning only applies
when the position that you are steel
manning is in good faith and i think
this is a corollary of it which is the
effect that this position actually can't
be steel manned at the present it still
exists and yet it can't be steel man is
an indicator that this isn't really
about your medical well-being it's about
something else that has not been
explained
and uh
anyway yeah i support this guy
um
however you pronounce his name however
right i mean he can pronounce his name
any way he'd like um
um but uh yes he is
bound to be better than the duplicitous
ken doll
man yeah who wouldn't
indeed
boy that's dangerous though
i'll bet they could come up with someone
worse
i bet they could come up with somebody
equally bad
no doubt
are you familiar with the book the
island of dr moreau h.g wells you are
okay i was not this was this came as
news to me so the question is if so no
i'm not going to tell you the question
first i'm going to tell you the question
but first can you say anything
well okay
okay i know that it exists i have not
read it okay um it is apparently and
this is from the
ever accurate wikipedia
the island of dr moreau was an 1896
science fiction novel by h.g wells
uh narration uh is a shipwrecked man
who is who finds himself on the island
home of dr moreau who's a mad scientist
who creates human-like hybrid beings
from animals via vivisection explores
lots of philosophical themes etc i think
that's all we need to know okay for the
question
if you found yourself shipwrecked on the
island of dr moreau and he offered to
enhance you with any animal trait or
ability what would it be
i would pick a monkey tail thanks
that's part of the question that's
probably that's not you that's not me uh
because i will i will say and this is
going to seem
stupidly professorial but uh i imagine
that what you mean when you say you pick
a monkey tail is you'd pick um one of
the species of new world monkeys that
have a prehensile tail that you want to
be able to both have a tail and hang
from it
almost all monkeys not all of them but
almost all monkeys have tails but
for the most part they're not very
useful
so it's the like spider monkeys and
their kin who have the prehensile tails
that's probably what you want
yeah i mean the real question is
you get to pick a an animal capability
yeah i don't mean i don't know what to
do with this one i feel a little bit
like with the music one like oh i want
lots of them it's hard to beat flight
hard to beat flight i mean it'd be cool
to be able to
to dance like a peacock spider that'd be
awesome i think everybody would would be
uh you know enhanced if that capacity
just existed
for any human really uh
what else
i mean i do think
some of the stuff going on in primates
where a few of the new world monkeys
have these prehensile tails and allows
them to swing
in the trees in a way
that is is unmatched otherwise but but
uh until you get to apes which is to say
none of none of the non-eight monkeys
actually have full actual brachiation
they don't have full rotation here
and so apes can do this brachiation
thing that's us
uh whereas the
not all of the new world monkeys uh have
this fifth appendage with which they
then have five
five things with which to kind of hang
through the trees and it allows them to
be really good climbers that that all
does look like a lot of fun it does look
like them i think i know what i want
though okay um i want
to be able to camouflage myself against
a tree like you're a platus
so europlatus is a clade of geckos in
madagascar the leaf tail here
yeah i'm sure something okay oh you want
me to just do google i mean i probably
have one of my photos but it's going to
be older so i'll just so i will tell you
that the problem with these creatures is
that their camouflage is really stunning
like beyond anything you can imagine but
it is almost impossible the
camera reveals them well somewhere i
actually have a great picture that you
took um that i used to teach with
um but i'm not gonna be able to pull it
up so i don't know i i'm looking up the
species that was on the island where i
did most of my work um because i know
that one to be particularly so the
problem glorious and cryptic
imagine an animal that can so this
animal is here revealed but imagine
that
pre-reveal
he just looks like tree barks that you
could actually get within a foot and not
realize that you're looking at a lizard
that's eight inches long well in the
jungle being the slippery place that it
is like i have found myself in
madagascar sort of slipping down a slope
and going to grab a tree to stabilize
myself which you can do in madagascar
you can't do in like the new world
tropics because there's no poisonous
snakes for instance it's the plants
that'll get you not the animals in
madagascar this is a good one um
and and almost grabbing and and you know
smashing your plate as a leaf tail gecko
because i couldn't see it in advance so
that's a different species i'm pretty
sure
yeah but i wasn't specie specific i just
want the ability to camouflage myself
i'm just saying i'm not sure
i i don't recognize this guy but you can
see like his fingers there yeah yeah um
and oh it says it's from briana's i
don't know it's in russian i don't know
um
yeah i'd love to find the
a really cryptic one here
now because this is what they do as soon
as you scare them up they go
they go
they do this and even even if you take a
picture of one against the tree there's
something about the camera
your eye yeah obscures this animal in a
way that a camera fails to yeah and
that's that's really not cryptic it
looks like it's cryptic but it's kind of
really not
it's pretty good it's pretty good
there's his head eyes hands
back tail his tail sort of plated down
against his feet which are also folded
back
yeah
totally yeah i don't know if it's a hem
you'd have to flip him over to look
okay uh
yeah
and i do i do like the both the
brachiation and the and well we have
brachiation though i do like the the
fifth the fifth prehensile element
that's pretty good that is pretty good
yeah yeah even the flying squirrel
gliding is pretty good i mean if you've
got to choose between that and flying
flying is cooler but yeah the flying
squirrel thing's pretty good yeah
um it probably wouldn't be my choice but
i guess you know the ability to
deep dive and hold your breath for an
hour
um that you know pinup heads for
instance can can pull off so glad you
don't look like an elephant seal
yeah i don't want to be an elephant seal
yeah no you don't no i don't want you to
be that one too thank you yeah thank you
they're nasty
not the females so much
yeah
okay when did we start zach how long
what are we at
just about exactly an hour okay um
let's do two more questions here shall
we
why should we be careful about allowing
music to be run by the markets
oh
because it's so
powerful
right and the thing is the market will
feed you
what
the market will feed you whatever it is
that
trivially triggers you
rather than something
that
is profound and deep and takes time for
you to
wrestle with its significance
so i think it's just the trivialization
it's enhanced the short time horizon and
the and the short term benefits the
short term rewards yeah and they sell
you all kinds of nonsense right stuff
that you might want to believe
but that isn't good for you but that
because people want to believe it is
resonant so there's all kinds of stuff
um
you know look if you're going to take
advice on
mating and dating you should take it
from
the arctic monkeys and not cardi b right
but
in terms of how likely you are to be
reached by a particular message it's the
inverse yeah right
yep
okay uh one more comment and then the
last question the comment which is a
suggestion peer review process
decentralized control of the gatekeepers
via blockchain
papers are nfts that can generate income
for the scientists and the reviewers
um
yeah on the other hand there's a
question there's something interesting
there i think it it forgets
how much additional work there is that's
not the scientists and the reviewers
like the the editors are doing real
real work like there's a lot of first
pass
stuff but yeah but i think i think we're
just over complicating the problem right
okay you want a scientific
structure that rewards
being right
way in advance of
others
right in other words the degree to which
something is important
is partially dependent on the magnitude
of the insight and partially dependent
on how early it it arrived so the whole
idea that we're going to gatekeep that
why are we gatekeeping oh because ink
and paper are expensive and we wouldn't
want to waste them on stuff that wasn't
true and the point is well we don't use
ink and paper anymore or at least we
don't need to and so the question is
look
i want to be able to say whatever it is
that i think needs to be said
and if you want to short it
good
all right we'll see we'll see if you're
right cool that's good for you if i'm
right it's good for me so and regardless
of who's right if this process works
it's good for science and it's good for
the world right and
isn't it good that all of the stuff
right if i want to say something and you
think it's laughable and i say it anyway
and you laugh and then
12 years down the road 15
years down the road it turns out i was
right then not only do you want to know
that but you also want to know oh
wasn't that laughable
it was laughable and yet it's true i
wonder how many other things that are
laughable might be true and how i might
spot them maybe i'll go into the
business of saying laughable things that
turn out to be true right that would be
good because if they're laughable that
means you're seeing them way ahead
so i just don't understand
we picked up a system that was literally
designed
to prevent us from wasting ink and paper
that's the only reason to do that level
of gatekeeping the rest of it is
benefited by just doing it all out in
the open and we can afford to do that
now because it's pixels so
let's do it at the pixel level and let's
you know if you if you you know don't
hide behind your goddamn anonymity as
you you know say that idea is crazy i
want you to say it out loud so that when
it turns out not to be crazy then that
uh you know degrades your reputation it
should
because if it's not really crazy you
shouldn't be saying that and if you
think it is crazy and it turned out not
to be that says something about what
quality of scientist you are
right that should all be out in the open
you should suffer the downside of
getting this stuff wrong rather than
being able to
snuff out people's careers privately
from behind some veil of anonymity no
sorry
do you have evolutionary last question
do you have evolutionary tips for weight
loss clearly our ancestors didn't evolve
to count calories is it just that they
were more active and inorganic
also fats versus carbs versus protein
that's a big question
that's a big big question um and it's
you know it's going to change it changes
over the lifespan it changes it's
different for men and women
it's different um probably there is a
lineage component uh in terms certainly
in terms of like what foods you may be
most likely to be most
might be the best fit for you
there are going to be some
some lineage level
components to that
um
but yeah a lot a lot of it's going to be
about the source of the food
and you know the the height as as
michael pollan writes in the omnivores
dilemma
the vast majority of stuff that's not
sold on the perimeter of supermarkets
isn't real food isn't good for you and
avoiding that just putting the stuff
that's not on the perimeter of a grocery
market a grocery store if if that's
where you get your food
uh and
being a lot more active will go a long
long way
and you know you want to go farther than
that mix it up be active in different
ways be active throughout the day
don't do the same thing over and over
again
and with regard to food consider growing
you know
growing your own food most of us don't
have that as a possibility
grow it you'll buy it from people who
grow it as close to you as as you can
who used techniques that were
as
as unlike the kinds of techniques that
produced the food in the center of the
supermarket as possible
all of that is spoken from a place of
actual privilege
and many many people don't have access
to answers that sound like that
so i would add a few things one you got
to know
why there's an issue right your
ancestors were starving right almost all
of them and much of the time maybe they
had a good season but the point is the
year
is a a
uh a cyclic
confrontation between people and a limit
on resources
so
probably the solution
um and i don't think i don't think we
humanity know it and i certainly don't
know it but probably the solution
involves getting control of the
informational architecture and sending
the right information into the system so
that it does not put on weight in order
to get through famines that are unlikely
to happen
that's one thing
i will say personally speaking
it is very easy to break
it's very easy to bend almost any rule
you would make and that for me the thing
that works best is a rule that's so dead
simple that you can't really bend it
right like um like you know really fast
intermittent fasting where there's an
hour of the day where you don't get to
eat before this hour and then you figure
out some way to make sure um you know
that what you do eat after that hour is
limited right
so
that's significant and i would also say
that the
tendency to put on weight with age
i believe is an adaptation and it's
probably one that at least as long as
our food supply is consistent has
outlived its usefulness
but that understanding that the very
fact of people
outliving their direct capacity to
reproduce
of outliving their capacity to be
productive in terms of generating food
is itself interesting that we have old
people
presumably because the content of their
minds has been traditionally very useful
and maybe the capacity to do certain
things like while younger people are out
being productive to
you know
mind the the home front and make sure
predators don't come in or something
like that or raise the kids right or
raise the kids george esterbrook's uh
work in the shale hills of portugal
which he was a professor of ours in grad
school and we write about him in the
book as well yeah so anyway the point is
if you're wired just as with what we
discussed last week um you're badly
wired with respect to what your limbs
should do with your circulation when
it's cold you're also badly wired with
respect to how you should view
food its abundance its scarcity etc
modernity inverts the logic of some of
these things and a lot of us would be
better off if it hadn't right but
in ancestral times it would make sense
for older people to put on weight when
food was abundant so that during scarce
times it was cheaper to keep them around
and
if that's what we're up against then it
says something about
a to the extent that there's a solution
where it's likely to be
um and b
why it's an issue it's you know the
willpower paradigm is no better than the
um
than the
uh chemical imbalance paradigm for
mental disorders right it's no better
than the
hijacking paradigm
for chemical addiction
all of these things stand in for a
richer
but more difficult puzzle beneath which
is the reason that we have failed to
solve any of them well we haven't
confronted the full complexity of the
problem yet so i suspect it's that
good
a lot more to say of course but uh let's
let's end there yep shall we i forgot to
say at the top of either of these hours
that we're gonna be coming to you early
next week
uh because someone has a plane to catch
what i know that's you oh and toby
yes um so early and probably no q a
although we'll see if we can maybe do a
really short one or something so when
you say early you're talking about early
on the same day so it's gonna be a week
from a week from today um but it will
not be at noon 30 because if we start at
noon 30 you'd be more significant
yeah it would be bad
so we'll be back in a week
but slightly earlier than than when we
usually are here
um
please go take a look at uh at our
patreons if that description of the
discord community sounded interesting to
you we encourage you to join to join
there
and as always we encourage you to
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside see you next
saturday
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you